[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
this is a ymh exclusive ymhi
i'm tim dillon
i'm a comedian but more importantly i'm
the biggest fan the city of austin texas
has ever had i'm going to be
in
the greatest city in the world
that's right
austin texas
on a special
your mom's house live
on august 17th the center of commerce
and culture austin texas
it may be 108 degrees but it feels cool
in the shade austin texas get food from
a truck
or enjoy
the brown river austin
texas
your mom's house live
today is tuesday august 9th and we're
just one week away from what could be
the best your mom's house live event yet
a few weeks ago it was announced that
tim dillon and josh potter are joining
tom sagar and christina p for your mom's
house live number eight it's coming out
wednesday august 17th
and by all means it should be one of
their best live shows ever tim dillon
and tom segura are two of honestly my
favorite comedians two of my favorite
podcasters and this live event where
there's less rules less restrictions of
what you can do what you can say these
two guys going at it along with
christina p obviously and josh potter
doing the live pre-show you also have
danny brown on the show too so it makes
for a very uh anticipated event welcome
back to the joke world comedy update
every single week bring you the comedy
news that you need to know from your
favorite podcasters your favorite
comedians your favorite comedy podcasts
whether it be guest appearances new
specials new stand-up dates uh tours
everything you need to know so please
consider subscribing to joke world right
now to stay in the comedy loop
downloading this episode on spotify to
support the channel so they're calling
it a summer blockbuster event starring
tom segura and christina p with
co-starring guest tim dillon and musical
guest danny brown pre-show hosted by
josh potter so the live stream starts at
ten dollars but that does not get you
access to the josh power pre-show for
that you have to pay 49
in the second package they're offering
for 49 bucks the vip pre-show with josh
potter and a hat that says heavy on it
because of their heavy segments
obviously fifty dollars is a ton of
money for a live stream podcast event
the ten dollar base
package i i agree with that's more than
fair but 50 bucks for this seems like a
lot but then if you really break it down
i mean that's only 40 more dollars that
they're adding for the josh potter live
show which should be pretty funny and
then also the hat you get a piece of
merch and they have to ship that and
whatnot that's fine i guess that adds up
if you think about it that way but i
wish there was a third option that you
don't get the hat and you can still
watch the josh potter pre-show for like
20 25 bucks maybe because i don't really
care if i get a heavy hat
but i do want to watch the josh power
part so i don't know i'm not sure i'm
definitely gonna buy one of the packages
uh we'll see let me know what you think
if you're gonna skip this event
completely get the ten dollar package to
see tom score and tim dillon on a live
event or if you're going all in with the
fifty dollar uh heavy package
tiavan is now the new owner of austin
texas after just dominating the comedy
scene there last week he was the guest
on kill tony and then also had joe rogan
on his podcast this past weekend they
filmed it in joe's studio which is kind
of funny because it seems like it's an
episode of jre but it's actually way
different
joe being the guest and theo being the
interviewer the person leading the
conversation i think joe rogan was able
to relax a lot more and be more open to
theo's just you know silly ideas dude my
sister you uh one time was using drugs
sorry i love you babe but um
she uh
and she's awesome she's like
i love her so much and but she did some
she got high with some guy on a date
right and they did they went rock
climbing which seems insane to do in
your high and ended up at a nudist
colony on top yeah i like it of some
small plateau yeah
wow
pretty cool imagine falling naked oh i
mean it's not like clothes are gonna
protect you but you'd feel like they
would
there's something about falling from the
it would be extra scary to fall naked
dude say you're falling right all right
you have a turtleneck on do you put your
head
[Laughter]
do you put your head inside or not i
don't think you even think about it yeah
you do probably have a heart attack you
don't think about it you think about it
you're that's what you do you're the
best thinker whereas in the past on the
joe rogan experience i feel like joe is
more likely to shoot down some of theo's
ideas or not go along with his jokes or
maybe some go over his head this one he
was way more relaxed and thea was the
one i mean it's his podcast so it was
just way different and it was
super funny i would definitely recommend
watching that full episode if you
already haven't
it came out earlier today and i've
watched your pace over there i remember
when i did a show with you in atlanta
and then we went to
we did a show the night before then we i
was sitting behind you and so like you
you guys are commentating and then you
go right up into the ring and you come
right back down and you commentate again
i mean it was like watching like a
it just seemed like a lot like this is a
lot you know like you have to have a
real pace for it it's a real job yeah
you have to have energy for sure it blew
my mind yeah it's like and you're doing
it for six hours yeah and i sit down for
six hours and i try not to pee which is
lucky that i have good experience doing
the podcast because i'm used to like
holding my piss for three hours but
that's about my limit so i always have
to pee at least once or twice
baby you know i like riding that bag
hard though sometimes like also i'm
drinking like monster energy drinks
sometimes which are like piss magnets
yeah yeah
yeah they're delicious but they make you
want to pee make you want to beat your
wife too dude i've seen a lot of dudes
drinking monster that you know they're
going home to punch
i don't know if the monster is the cause
of it i think there's probably other
other factors well i'll say this it's
the beverage of choice of some of those
gentlemen
i'll say that
i thought it was rock stars
maybe it used to be the kill tony
episode was honestly just as funny
that's like a perfect environment for
thea to thrive i feel like being on the
kill tony panel you know just saying
things off the top of his head
interacting with all these comedians and
the other comedians on the panel the
people going up to do their 60 seconds
you my girl and you just gonna break up
with me
oh [ __ ] break up with me all right just
break up with you yeah
can i
i'm just asking can i use the n-word or
not
[Applause]
i ain't
gonna say
[Applause]
hey theo
i don't care but when we step out of
here i can't help it
[Applause]
but you use it at your discretion okay
[Music]
do whatever you want
hey ellis hey
hey hey what's up baby what's going on
you know what the [ __ ] up boo
my little
baby why are you censoring the word
[ __ ] you know you saying really
that was a call came in i ain't
censoring [ __ ]
i know you've been out there with mr joe
petting them [ __ ] white animals what
what the
what baby what
i know you've been out there with papa
joe
petting them little [ __ ] honky
muppets
shonda you crazy baby look um not as
crazy as your homeless ass is
i'm out this relationship
[Applause]
[Music]
real quick i just want to say thank you
again for the 100 000 subscriber mark
the play button just got here yesterday
in the mail and i just want to show you
guys say thank you again um
it's pretty cool
as for shows from last week your mom's
house had on bobby lee and kalyla that
was their first podcast guest appearance
i believe since breaking up two bears
one cave was burt and tom the joe rogan
experience had on sam tripoli kfc from
barstool was on the honeydew with ryan
sickler theovonne and this past weekend
had on joe rogan ethan klein was on
tiger belly from h3 uh whiskey ginger
had on fajimar noir kill tony also had
on theo von kill tony's the best show
for comedy for stand-ups like up and
coming stand-ups there's no better
atmosphere no better and it's the
cornerstone of stand up in austin
because it's such a good show and you
for one minute all you have to do is
just be funny all that woke [ __ ] all
that virtue signaling all that's out the
window all that like posing you got one
minute you better come with some jokes
come with some jokes yeah or just come i
think people would laugh at that dude if
somebody got up there and bats down for
a second it depends on where it lands i
don't know dude i pantsed bert
christopher during one yeah i pulled his
[ __ ] pants down he had no underwear
on his his ass was half hanging out he
stood up and he raised his his arms up
in the air and he took his shirt off and
i [ __ ] pulled his pants right down
show him that [ __ ]
yeah yeah he should just go full nudist
how long
how long until burke pressure goes fully
nude well he did something the other day
with a [ __ ] with a sock over his [ __ ] he
was doing something and at that point
you're just a damn nine iron dude you
know what i'm saying he's halfway to
[ __ ] nudity flagrant had a very funny
episode with louis ck and joe list and
then today they talked with the youtuber
ksi i think netflix was trying to like
replace tv we were talking about this a
little bit before but yeah we don't want
tv replaced right we just want the best
stories so instead of making a million
different shows make a few that we're
really interested in make a couple
movies and then have enough like uh what
i call like laundry tv like friends yeah
like i already know friends i've watched
a million times it's just on in the
background while i'm going to sleep or
something no that's what i remember when
i was a kid and you don't watch
his friends
[ __ ] nerd
what a [ __ ] loser pivot pivot right
andrew pippen yikes tickets
could you be more lame
[Laughter]
i knew when i said to you
i love friends i love friends [ __ ] man
how do i be cool joe friends thanks
uh seinfeld that's how you'd be cool
just stinks
seasons three through seven oh
oh wait you're like picky about which
season i'm a seinfeld [ __ ] when larry
left it just became very silly it's very
frustrating when people reference
seasons eight and nine i'm like i can't
be friends with you you stick gotcha so
you're a larry fan well i mean larry's
my guy yeah he's the best he is the best
he's just trying to get his way
back to louie he's the
true king of comedy now he is very good
i opened for larry david years ago when
he was a stand-up what was his stand-up
like
brilliant and impossible to i i was the
emc actually okay
and a guy named bob shaw was a headliner
he was a great comic
and uh larry was this feature act it was
in cambridge massachusetts at the
catch rising star and uh so they told me
you have to watch this guy's whole set
because he blows up and leaves a lot he
walks off stage a lot he won't do a lot
of times he won't finish his set because
he gets angry
so they said you have to stay in the
room and be ready to jump on
and oh not for joy no no
yeah in case you just leave it early i
thought it was like you got to see this
they're saying we need you to be stand
by okay
and i didn't know anything about him i
never heard of him and he i he instantly
became my favorite comedian the
audiences didn't know what to do with
him
but he had these great bits like um
he says i could if if i was
complimented by joseph mengele i would
have liked him like if he get paid me
but yeah yeah yeah and he does this
thing larry david your hair looks good
today is it really dramatic
oh yeah oh yeah
thank you you mentally not a bad guy not
many new specials came out last week you
still have whitney cummings jokes on
netflix and then jeremiah watkins came
out with a new stand up on the spot
today so go check that out it's on
youtube that does it for this episode of
the joke world comedy update be sure to
come back next week we usually do these
on mondays today we did on tuesday but
next monday we'll be back with some more
comedy news be sure to subscribe to joke
world give this video a like and go
check out you know some of our other
videos
if you want if not that's cool too
all right thanks for watching
[Music]
you